c'est l'heure de la répétition pour
frigo et son maître à seulement vingt
mois ce bulldog anglais élevé à saint
roch représente à lui tout seul l'élite
de la race déjà auréolé du titre de
champion de france il va se rendre
dimanche au salon de l'agriculture afin
de participer au concours général
agricole pour permettre aux jurés
d'apprécier toutes ses qualités il doit
d'abord savoir rester immobile
on le met en statique ce qu'on appelle
en statique pour qui montre bien sa
largeur de mâchoires l'implantation des
babines le laid back ici l'alignement
montant néphrons
qu'il examine un peu la taille de la
tête sa forme puis
sa poitrine ses aplombs
et ensuite le juge lui va se déplacer
autour du chien pour voir à peu près sa
ligne de dos les aplombs arrière fait
c'est lui fuit gora plus d'une centaine
d'autres chiens du type molossoïde pas
sûr qu'il puisse l'emporter et puis le
jury pourrait être influencé par
l'actualité en début de mois la norvège
a interdit l'élevage des bouledogues
anglais la sélection aurait été trop
loin créant aux animaux des difficultés
respiratoires pour notre éleveur cette
participation parisienne est donc aussi
un acte militant
on veut montrer au grand public le
bulldog anglais c'est un chien qui peut
être en parfaite santé comme n'importe
quel autre race de chien que c'est un
chien qui peut courir sauter faire des
randonnées évidemment par des grandes
randonnées mais contrairement à ce qu'on
dit un chien qui peut se balader avec
vous une heure ou deux à un rythme
normal sans être essoufflée sans avoir à
le porter etc etc entre 70 et 80 chiot
naissent chaque année dans cet élevage
de saint roch en dépit de son jeune âge
et de son caractère joueur fuego est
déjà papa